in this video i'm going to show you how
to raise your prices it's one of the
best ways you can increase profitability
your business
and ultimately make more money and give
you more spending power pay people
better
provide better experience all of the
many benefits that go with raising your
prices but one of the fears of raising
your prices is what if i don't sell
anyone what if my sales team doesn't
have conviction
what if my market won't bear that price
99 times out of 100 it's
purely in your head and in your sales
team's head
but having now raised my prices in a
number of different businesses a number
of different industries across different
sales teams i have a process that has
worked
very very well for me and i'd like to
share with you okay so what i've written
here uh on the board here
different prices uh that i might be
increasing going from one thousand two
thousand two thousand three thousand
three thousand four thousand four to
five
six to eight ten to twelve these are
common price increases that
happen and what i want to do is kind of
walk you through the strategy
in a real way so that you can see what
this equates to
in a real business okay so if we're if
we're going right i'm trying to uh
increase from let's say 2k to 3k the way
that i do it is i actually
bump my my top price up by an additional
uh percent all right and so i actually
make the new price
four thousand dollars which is the price
acre this is what the sales people are
going to say on the phone
right and here's what's cool is that i
say cool you can pay this four thousand
dollars
in in 2k you know and 2k right you can
make that
that payment that way and the reason we
do that is because 2k is their their
emotional anchor
they're used to getting two thousand
dollars and so i'm gonna say cool you
still have that in your back pocket
you're totally fine it's safe it's gonna
be okay
right so we're gonna say it's four
thousand dollars which they can either
pay 2k a ticket or
they can get some same day savings and
pay 3k today
all right and so by doing this it allows
them emotionally to have
home base where they feel comfortable
and safe asking for two thousand dollars
right say cool and the extra payment you
can make in 30 days or if you want you
can just pre-pay it
and pay 3k so it actually gives the
sales people a discount
to get the price that is now higher for
us all right so let's walk
through another one because i think this
is uh this is something that's good to
to walk through together so let's do
this 4k one so
your 4000 you want to bump to 5000. all
right well again we're going to bump
over
to do we're going to skip over that 5k
and we're going to jump straight to 6k
this is going to be our new price
anchor and we're going to say cool what
i want to do is you can either pay 4k
today
and then 2k in 30 days now notice that
this is a disproportion slip i prefer to
do
uneven splits personally because i want
to still keep more cash up front right
and the reason this also is cool now
check this out right
remember this person always said 2k well
it's like well shoot i can either pay 2k
now 2k in a month or so or just an extra
thousand to get to the 3000 see how much
easier this is to sell
same thing happens here right you're at
six thousand dollars
you say cool 4k remember this is home
base this is what our sales team is used
to selling so they have conviction
around this number they're comfortable
saying something they don't get tongue
tied
around saying this number right it's
like or so you can pay 4k today and then
2k
in 30 days or you can just pay an extra
thousand and get it all
taken care of today right and so all of
a sudden you're down selling this upsell
you're down selling and making a
discount compared to a price anchor
which we introduced on the call so it
actually makes it easier for your sales
team to sell
now this process that i just outlined is
exactly how i raise prices because i've
done
i've tried to you know i've tried to
just say okay guys you just got to deal
with it it's just in your heads
but you know as time has gone on and
like i've become more weathered than
this
it's good to have a process and so a
couple of the takeaways that i want you
to see from this is
one is that they're going to have an
emotional comfort sailing around a
certain price you have to accept that
right
and there's a reason that you're the
entrepreneur because you tend to be a
little bit more adaptable a little bit
more flexible a little bit more growth
worries and that's okay right
but you have to meet people where
they're at and so if this is what
they're comfortable then we still need
to give that to them
so they still have that and that's what
they can always ask for up front right
and then the second thing that i want
you to take from this so first is that
you give them there
so i'll write numbers on this right
first is that you give them their home
base
number one all right number two is that
the price that we are going to
be anchoring is not the price that we're
actually trying to get to so if we want
to get to 3 000 from 2000 we're actually
going to talk about a 4 000
price point which anchors high and then
when we introduced
number three which is the prepayment
discount that is actually the number
that we're looking for
all right the fourth tidbit that i want
you to take from this is noticing the
discrepancy between what they can pay
today
versus what they're going to pay over
time all right i prefer to have an
uneven
split because a i'm going to have more
cost of onboarding i prefer to
make more cash flow up front and the
beautiful benefit
of just the tiny incremental increase
from that one payment from for
a 4k 2k split compared to just i just
pay 5k today and be done with that
creates a very compelling offer all
right now if i were to jump from let's
say
10k to 12k this is going to be a really
really minor difference right i could do
uh do this a couple of different ways i
could say you know 3 times 4k
right or what i would probably prefer is
something like
6 plus 3 plus 3 right so i get a little
bit more up front
for the payment and then more over time
now notice if i do six
super three then it's going to
automatically encourage people
far more to take this upfront prepayment
discount right it's like well for only
an extra
one more thousand than what i would make
on my second payment i don't have to
make any more payments
right and so you're noticing the four
points that are that are going to be
consistently used here
right is that one we're going to try and
give them home base as much as we can
right number two
we're going to jump over the number that
we're planning on trying to price it at
so we have a higher price anchor so that
we can down saw the prepayment discount
which is number three
and noticing that the comfort price
compared to the prepayment discount
should only be marginal
right and the reason we do that is
because they're like oh man it's just a
little bit extra and i can pay that now
but what we accomplished through doing
this and like that 4k that uneven split
is that now we've successfully raised
the price
we've gotten more people to prepay
because of the way that we structured
the pricing
and we've done it in such a way that the
sales team can feel confident and
convicted about it so they can sell
consistently without any issues and i'll
give you one more pro tip before we go
so if you're ever going to raise your
prices always
always always clear the
pipe all right so clear the pipeline so
announce it always
own your price increases it's one of the
easiest ways to create true scarcity and
urgency
all right so if your team knows that
this is going to happen then it gives
them urgency
to close more deals faster and clear out
the pipeline so give them a heads up say
hey
we're going to increase the price next
month hey we're gonna be increasing the
price in the next two weeks so it gives
people
this this motivation to take action and
not sit on the sidelines it allows your
team to squeeze
uh their pipeline to get some extra cash
now here's another side benefit of when
you clear the pipeline
when you do this it also gets around you
know some of those future people are
like i heard a different price etc well
it's like well we already gave you a
heads up about it we told you we're
gonna click
we're we're adding more more features
more benefits blah blah to
the thing we have more successes we're
making it easier and faster for you
and so as a result the price is going to
reflect that so get in now
right and then you as the business owner
get a nice boost of cash flow before you
make the change so that you can weather
maybe a dip in cash flow during the
adjustment period which sometimes
happens right it's just natural as part
of the business
all right so this is how you raise
prices in a tactical format this is how
i have learned
to do it has worked very well for me i
hope it works well for you
the point of this channel is there's a
lot of people who are
broke and i make these videos so that
you are not one of them i have nothing
to sell you keep being awesome hit this
crowd see the next video